you're being a little bit with fuckboy
and vague with your answers were you or
were you not was it just a situation
next video happy valentine's day
happy valentine's day i would say about
two years ago wait this guy looks like
me
playing the same nose a surprise la trip
uh for valentine's day we've been in the
room
um had some ideas what we were going to
do and then right before we were about
to leave
she gives me my gift um he was in a
little box
and there were these bud chocolates like
it looked like marijuana
but they were chocolates which was dope
and then the second surprise was two
tickets to see bobby lee
on valentine's day at the comedy store
and
me being a comedy fan it was like a
dream come true
actually going to the comedy store and
experiencing it and
seeing the names up on the wall and
like even now i miss it even only being
there once and i i miss it you know
um but that was my valentine story the
red chocolates
oh here it is
that's the one
oh no way
[Laughter]
who are we gonna go see i'm gonna see
bobby lee
let's go baby that's nice
you are korean elvis you are the korean
that's why
that's why i wanted to show that [ __ ] up
all right maybe you are korean and you
know what you are babe you're the
uh filipino aaron sorkin
that's a compliment i know maybe i am
the filipino
[Laughter]
that was really nice that was really
sweet i couldn't stop
i could he looked so much like me like
he could be a relative one of those face
things
it's crazy which kind of people that
look at you maybe like me maybe
is that the thing where people that look
like like you and i
maybe you like the way i look right
maybe and maybe
because i'm kind of like jessica you
know what that's a very
fair fair theory right and then i i
gravitate toward people that look like
you the cross eye with the nose you know
what i mean
yeah yeah maybe you got cross-eyed with
a nose too baby
that's what i'm saying maybe there's
something there you know we like
our types of people just like each other
let me tell you when you first met
jessica
it was like long-lost siblings reunited
you guys are the same
kind of fiery kind of you think that's
why george also liked jessica yeah and
why george also liked you
same fascination but
let's be clear jessica is like half your
size and like 90 pounds
with long hair and way more attractive
whoa see that's funny
funny that you would throw that in see
that's funny that's comedy um
[ __ ] you okay also if you happy a few
key differences
project manager for you know um
nasa you know what i mean very very
organized very on top of her game
pioneer in the industry oh very similar
to you pioneer korean elvis babe
[Music]
anyway any and helpful advice any other
yes let's do another unhelpful advice
babe let's connect
no you attack you can't attack in the
connect let's connect no no we'll
connect later give me
all right here for real right here
okay you guys good yeah we're good
okay